في تحديده اولويات جيشه لعام 2023 تعهد
بوتن بمواصله تعزيز القدرات العسكريه بما
في ذلك النوويه ومنذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا انتشر الحديث عن استخدام السلاح
النوويه جول هذا الحديث هو التاكيد على
عدم استخدام السلاح ولكن النفي في حد ذاته
يشير الى احتماليه احتماليه موجوده فما هو
سيناريو الحرب النوويه مجله نيتشر وضعت
سيناريو التخيلي تبدا فيه الحرب النوويه
بعيدا عن الطرفين الاشهر الولايات المتحده
وروسيا ولكن بين لاعبين غير متوقعين
لاسباب قوميه هنا الحرب بين باكستان
والهند
[تصفيق]
تبدا الازمه في هذا السيناريو عام
اشتباكات في منطقه كشمير المتنازع عليها
بين البلدين مع ازدياد التوتر تبدا دوله
في تفجير عده قنابل نوويه فترد الاخرى
بالمثل عدد القنابل المتفجره في هذا
السيناريو هو 100 من كل دوله اي 200 قنبله
في المجموعه
كل قنبله بحجم قنبلات هيروشيما الاثر
المباشر هو 21 مليون شخص في تلك المنتقه
من العالم المقتضي بالسكان كما ستدمر مئات
المدن بعد ذلك يرتفع الدخان كما نشاهد
عاليا في الغلاف الجوي في الكوكب بغطاء من
الرماد فيحجب اشعه الشمس ليغرق كوكبنا في
بروده عميقه سنوات
يطلق عليه الخبراء اسم الشتاء النووي هنا
نتحدث عن حرب النوويه بين قوتين لا تمتلك
احداهما اكثر من 150 راس نوويه هذا الشتاء
سيؤدي الى فشل المحاصيل في عشرات البلدان
وبالتالي يا ليندادات الغذائيه لاكثر من
مليار شخص حول العالم هؤلاء سيتاثرون
اما المحيط فليس احسن حالا ستتغير كيمياء
المياه لتصبح حمضيه
فتموت الشعب المرجانيه التي تحافظ على
النظام البيئي وستمت الاسماك مصدر غذاء
اخر لم يعد موجوده
اما السيناريو الاخر فهو الحرب النوويه
الكامله بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه النتيجه كارثيه صدقوني سيرتفع
10050 مليون طن من الرماد في الغلاف الجوي
وسط تنخفض درجات الحراره العالميه باكثر
من عشر درجات مئويه وبعد عامين من هذه
الحرب ستؤدي السماء المظلمه الى عكس اتجاه
الرياح سيصيب الجفاف الشديد مناطق عده في
العالم ومناطق اخرى ستتعرض لامطار غزيره
وسيول مدمره بالنسبه للغذاء ستنهار مناطق
خلال الغذاء خلال الخبز العالميه في الغرب
اوسط في الولايات المتحده وايضا في
اوكرانيا احتياطات الحبوب التي نعرفها
ستختفي في غضون عامل
سيكون الامر اسوء من اي مجاعه في التاريخ
الذي نعرفه
تقول مجله نيتشر ان المحصل نهائيا للحرب
التي يستخدم فيها الانسان فقط واحد بالمئه
من الترسانه الموجوده لديه حاليا
ستدمر الامدادات الغذائيه على كوكب الارض
وحول مصير الانسان فيعتقد اننا لن ننقرض
سيبقى عدد قليل منا من البشر على هذا
الكوكب لكنهم سيكونون منهكين لانهم
سيبداون ببناء حضاره ولكن